Tania here in the United States we had
the Boy Scouts of America it's a very
important institution and basically
since the 1960s the United States Chess
Federation was trying to get the Boy
Scouts of America to give him merit
badge two for chess through the Boy
Scouts of America at that so that they
encouraged the kids to play chess
decades went by we never got anywhere
until Jeannie Sinquefield who happened
to have her best friend on the on the
Boy Scouts of America committee got a
merit mat for chess and right next door
as we speak
boy Boy Scouts from all over the United
States are getting their merit badges by
taking their chest tests and figuring
out the moves and so there we've got on
some footage of them yes there you see
them with their outfits so we do have
something similar where we do not have a
genie sink unfortunately who is got this
program going which is yeah which is
besides being ridiculously cute is
actually amazing so I was having a word
with dr. Jenny Sinquefield
the other day by the way she's the
reason why we're all here okay today
right now here but she was telling me a
very interesting thing that it's chess
and maths and music if with these three
things both parts and if you you do a
science experiment what parts of your
brain light up these are the three
fields that actually light up the
intuitive as well as the logical part of
the brain and it's interesting that in
chess math and music is where you have
your prodigies that's where you hear
about math prodigies and so forth and we
we definitely have our project using
chance they're absolutely